his home is disgusting I compared it to
what I called Gotham City the streets
are filthy there's so much crime in the
city I can't I can't comprehend how
people live there it was repulsive it
smells bad and I just I think it's a
terrible place if AOC
went on MSNBC and said I went down to
Dalton Georgia
and the crime rate is way higher than
New York City it was disgusting the
average income per capita isn't even 22
thousand dollars there's no jobs there's
no money it was terrible disgusting
place
imagine if AOC did that on MSNBC about
Dalton AOC and everyone on the right
would be saying they constantly insult
our part of the country they think that
we're stupid they think this they think
that they think we're backwards